figaro live 19h50 bonsoir bienvenue on
en a vu des allocutions du président de
la république pendant cinq ans certaines
ont été marquantes comme pendant la
crise des gilet jaune ou le soir de
l'annnonce du confinement d'autres ont
été plus honnête de anecdotique tombé
dans l'oubli dans quelle classe dans
quelle case classera ton celles ci on en
saura plus d'ici là les dix minutes quoi
qu'il en soit de ses allocutions peut on
était aussi attendu la france semble
ingouvernable emmanuel macron s'exprime
devant les français à 20h ce soir
bonsoir il ya une requête bonsoir
thibault merci d'être ici directeur de
la rédaction du figaro magazine bombe il
était obligé la le président de prendre
la parole alors il n'était pas obligé
parce que c'est une sorte de surprise
tant qu'on ne savait pas exactement
quand ils devaient s'exprimer mais oui
c'est une obligation politique on a le
sentiment que
à l'elysée on est aux abonnés absents
c'est qu'il ya eu un séisme politique
dimanche dernier il y a eu un discrédit
assez claire du président de la
république vous vous souvenez c'était
mardi donc il ya huit jours il était sur
le tarmac d'orly et 10 et donnez moi une
majorité solide et vrais malades
français retirent en ukraine exactement
les français n'ont pas voulu lui donner
donc comment il comprend ça
quelle conséquence il souhaite en tirer
il était temps qu'il nous en dise un peu
plus oui surtout qu'on rappelle qu'il
ouvre une séquence internationale il
part à l'absolu elle demain ils semblent
pris là à madrid en allemagne d'abord
pour un sommet du g7 après un sommet de
l'otan à madrid une conférence de l'onu
à lisbonne non qu'il va quitter le pays
il pouvait pas se dissocier du de la
politique nationale comme ça en quelques
jours je pense qu'il ne fallait surtout
pas refaire la même erreur que la
semaine dernière où on lui a beaucoup
reproché à juste titre d'expliquer sur
ce fameux tarmac d'orly que la
république était non pas en danger mais
que s'il y avait un moment important qui
a les vivres et et lui qu'est ce qu'il
faisait il monter dans son avion oui
c'est vrai c'est qu'on leur a dit que le
navire exactement où en tout cas
débrouillez vous tout seul alors il et
il est maintenant alors on sait pas
vraiment les c'est toujours pareil
est-ce que c'est enregistré ce que c'est
en direct où ce sera dans l'elysée on
sait que des fois avec le jardin
derrière donc on verra tout ça sur sur
la forme mais la ddt sur l'exercice
c'est purement politique il a fait des
allocutions on peut les récapituler on
s'en souvient pour faire des annonces la
plupart du temps avec les gilet jaune
notamment avec la pandémie ou dans des
moments solennels comme pour la
cathédrale de notre dame là c'est
purement politique ce qui va faire ce
soir il a pas encore fait cet exercice
si non et je dirais même plus c'est
purement défensif et c'est la première
fois emmanuel macron a eu une
trajectoire politique assez bruissante
faut bien en convenir il n'avait jamais
été élu ils se retrouvent pression' à 2
0 très jeune il fait exploser la gauche
et la droite y créer un parti ex nihilo
qui obtient la majorité absolue en 2017
à l'assemblée nationale si totale
réussite totale il a géré la pandémie
plutôt bien il a été réélu à 58% il ya
plus de deux mois maintenant hélas pour
la première fois il se prend le mur et
ça va être très intéressant même d'un
point de vue personnel même d'un point
de vue presque psychologique comment
est-ce qui réagit face à ça est ce qu'il
est dans le déni ou vous pensez qu'on
peut le sentir ça ce soir on a les
médias mais déjà vu déjà vous allez
l'écouter si vous voulez candy dit il
peut être dans le déni il peut dire
ma majorité est le groupe le plus
important de l'assemblée nationale
personne d'autre n'est susceptible
d'avoir une majorité de gouvernement
jean luc mélenchon a échoué dans sa
volonté d'être premier ministre et tout
comme et tout continue comme avant il
pourrait faire ça ils vont être dans ce
dans ce déni moi je pense qu'il est trop
intelligent pour ça mais c'est un ça va
être intéressant de voir dans quelle
mesure est ce qu'ils acceptent le
message que lui ont envoyé les frontons
que ce que vous attendez plus là d'ici
sept minutes et on suivra sur sur le
figaro l'a évidemment sur youtube
surtout il sur lefigaro.fr vous
réagissez ce que vous attendez c'est
presque ce qu'il va pour comment il va
réagir parce que son attitude plus que
cet exercice d'équilibriste très
politique par exemple chirac avait
dissout l'assemblée dans une allocution
comme ça on en est loin évidemment mais
c'est quelque chose de très politique ce
que les français le comprennent cette
tambouille politicienne là ce soir à 20
heures je pense que les français ont
envoyé un message au président de la
république et lui ont dit on ne veut pas
que ça continue comme avant on ne veut
pas renverser la table on veut pas la
révolution on veut pas de mélenchon à
matignon mais on ne veut pas que vous
continuez à être jupiter et puis il y à
une colère qui s'exprime en particulier
avec l'avènement surprise avec l'arrivée
plutôt de 89 députés rassemblement
national ça dit quelque chose de l'état
du pays est-ce qu emmanuel macron a
compris ce message là et surtout comment
il le comprend quelle conséquence il va
en tirer c'est ça qui est important à la
fois d'un point de vue institutionnel
est-ce qu'ils gardent madame bornes il
lui est il le lui a dit hier améliorer
voire il puisse la renvoyer vous avez
raison mais il peut dire il peut lui
donner une échéance en disant
ah oui ce serait intéressant ça voilà en
disant je j'ai confié une mission à
madame la première ministre et elle me
rendras compte dans quelques semaines il
peut donner des échéances il peut aussi
nous dire ce qu'il veut faire hier il a
reçu fabien roussel le patron du parti
communiste et il lui a parlé d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale
il a reçu tout le monde en vous voyez ce
matin d' rien qu'à tenant ce qui
représente la nuque c'est surtout la
france insoumise il a reçu aussi ce
matin julien bayou d'europe écologie les
verts et hier soir fabien roussel des
communistes du passé à cames en voilà et
expliquez nous cette histoire d'union
nationale oui je voulais venir là dessus
parce que on en parle beaucoup depuis
trois jours qu'est ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que c'est envisageable alors un
gouvernement d'union nationale c'est un
gouvernement dans lequel tout où les
principales couleurs de de l'échiquier
politique sont représentés ça a existé
dans l'histoire la dernière fois c'était
en 1945 où le général de gaulle avait
constitué un gouvernement à la sortie de
la seconde guerre mondiale dans lequel
il y avait de mémoire quatre communistes
quatre socialistes de mrp l'équivalent
du centre droit sauf que il y avait des
raisons pour ça la france avait été
envahi l'armée allemande avaient défilé
sur les champs-elysées ou ligne se passe
rien de tel cette fois ci donc on est
très très loin oui donc déjà le cadre et
des bars du tout le monsieur monsieur
macron est en difficulté mais ça ne
justifie pas un gouvernement d'union
nationale et il le sait très bien
qu'elle avait arrêté devrait pour les
autres en plus de faire ça mais à aucun
c'est pour ça il fait semblant de le
proposer pour pouvoir dire aux français
peut-être qu'il commencera déjà à le
faire ce soir regardez j'ai tendu la
main aux différences forces politiques
j'ai essayé de sortir de cette crise
institutionnelle
parce que les français ils aiment bien
le côté si tous les gars du monde
voulait se donner la main ça leur plaît
ça fait partie des mythes fondateurs de
notre vie publique c'est l'unité
nationale et donc il peut essayer dans
une stratégie
politique tactique de
remettre sur ses opposants la
responsabilité de l'impasse dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons pas certain
que les autres acceptent de servir
au-delà du discours convenu j'ai entendu
le message des français je vous ai
entendu on sait que
il est parfois un peu vague dans ses
allocutions et parfois de lorsqu'il
termine bombe qu'en retenir là ce soir
je pense qu'il doit être plus concret
non oui en général d'abord général il
est trop long oui parce que c'est ainsi
grèce voilà c'est un de ces grands
défauts le président la république a
parfois tendance à s'enivrer un petit
peu de son ou de son propre discours et
il me semble que c'est peut-être aussi
cela que les français ont rejeté ils
veulent une une rapport un peu plus
direct un peu plus concret et un peu
plus précis avec leurs responsables
politiques si vous étiez l'un des
conseillers d'emmanuel macron là trois
choses qu'il doit dire ce soir allez
devrait dire qu'il pourrait dire d'abord
je pense qu'il faut qu'il dise j'ai
entendu
ce message de désaveu je vous ai demandé
de majorité claire une majorité solide
vous ne l'avez pas donné j'ai entendu le
message deuxièmement qu'ils nous donnent
une direction est ce qu'il dit je vais
consulter les partis
de gouvernement
socialistes républicains pour essayer de
former une coalition avec eux il faut
qu'il donne une feuille de route et puis
je pense aussi qu'il faut qu'ils donnent
une direction politique ce qui est
difficile aujourd'hui c'est que qui sont
il n'y a pas vraiment de gagnant à cette
élection mais qui sont les gens qui
progresse le plus c'est l'extrême gauche
et l'extrême droite c'est le clan de
jean luc mélenchon et le club de marine
le pen
entre ces deux messages envoyés est-ce
qu'il y en a un qui choisi d'écouter
davantage que les autres bref il faut
qu'il nous donne un cap un cap mais mais
mais toujours six ou sept sous cette
forme plutôt court plutôt long on a vu
des fois des allocutions moins de dix
minutes défaut à 25 30 35
quel est le meilleur cas dans le
meilleur équilibre et vaut mieux faire
court non je pense qu'il va faire court
parce que il me semble qu'il n'est pas
prêt encore à a dévoilé une stratégie
nouvelle on a l'impression qu'il est
plus fort c'est par l'actualité obligé
de répondre obligé de s'exprimer à un
moment ou un autre que vraiment annoncer
quelque chose en tout cas ce qui
accrédite cette idée c'est
ce petit échange par par communiqués
interposés avec la première ministre
celui-ci a présenté sa démission celle
ci pardon a présenté sa démission et
emmanuel macron la refuser donc s'il
avait déjà un plan évidemment il n'y
aurait pas eu cet échange est rien
n'obligeait institutionnellement
elisabeth borne à remettre sa démission
l'institution ne dit pas après une
élection législative
le premier ministre doit doit remettre
son son son poste entre les mains du
président de la république tôt si l'on
choisit cet échange c'est un petit
message qui a été envoyé en dix ans pour
l'instant je ne ne bouscule pas le
dispositif donc sauf grande surprise
moi ce que je pense c'est que voisine on
va dire je vous ai entendu et je
consulte pour essayer de trouver un
chemin j'ai pas si vous avez vu il y
avait plusieurs sondages qui disait que
les français étaient favorables à une
forme de cohabitation c'est à dire à une
forme de gouvernement commun alors on
n'ira pas jusqu'à nous nationale mais il
peut il peut tendre la main encore une
fois soit sur sa gauche soit sur sa
droite où les deux d'ailleurs peut-être
et ce serait un moyen de de dire aux
français j'ai compris que vous vouliez
une nouvelle façon de gouverner il est
20h et nous attendons évidemment les
images de l'elysée et cette allocution
d'emmanuel macron le président de la
république qui s'expriment trois jours
après la défaite enfin la défaite oui il
n'a pas gagné totalement il a gagné il a
la majorité la majorité relative il
s'exprimera donc devant les français
d'un instant à l'autre depuis l'elysée
on suivra tout ça on analyse tout ça
avec guillaume roquette à la fin de
cette allocution tiens guillaume est ce
que ce soir il peut donner en attendant
je me plains petit peu en attendant que
les images nous arrive évidemment est ce
qu'il peut nous met précisément vous
parle de ça ça m'intéresse elisabeth
borne à le président de la république il
est là et on les écoute ignorait la
forte abstention qui nous oblige tous à
redonner davantage de sens à nos actions
collectives de lisibilité au grand
rendez vous démocratique
voter est essentielle pour la vie de la
nation pour ces grands choix est très
clairement ce n'est plus ressentie par
tous je ne peux pas davantage ignorer
les fractures les divisions profondes
traverse notre pays et se reflète dans
la composition de la nouvelle assemblée
elles expriment des inquiétudes le
sentiment d'avoir des vies bloqué pas de
perspective dans nombre de nos quartiers
populaires comme dans nos villages
ces élections législatives ont fait de
la majorité présidentielle la première
force politique de l'assemblée nationale
toutefois et c'est un fait nouveau et
comme dans la plupart des démocraties
occidentales qu'il s'agisse de
l'allemagne de l'italie de beaucoup
d'autres aucune force politique ne peut
aujourd'hui faire les lois seul il a
manqué une trentaine de députés sur 577
et la majorité présidentielle est en
effet relative
sa responsabilité est donc de s'élargir
soit en bâtissant un contrat de
coalition soit en construisant des
majorités texte par texte oui pour agir
dans votre intérêt dans celui de la
nation nous devons collectivement
apprendre à gouverner et légiférer
différemment
bâtir avec les formations politiques
constituant la nouvelle assemblée des
compromis nouveau dans le dialogue
l'écouté le respect c'est ce que vous
avez souhaité et j'en prends acte cela
ne doit pas vouloir dire l'immobilisme
cela doit signifier des accords en
prenant le temps de les faire
par le dialogue le respect d'exigences
j'entends et suis décidé à prendre en
charge la volonté de changement que le
pays a clairement exprimé
parce que c'est mon rôle comme garant de
nos institutions j'ai échangé hier et
aujourd'hui avec les dirigeants de
l'ensemble des formations politiques qui
sont en capacité de constituer un groupe
à l'assemblée nationale
je crois à retranscrire avec justesse la
teneur de nos entretiens en soulignant
d'abord que tous ont fait part de leur
respect pour nos institutions et de leur
volonté d'éviter un blocage pour notre
pays je salue cet esprit de
responsabilité je souhaite qu'il
s'inscrive dans la durée la plupart des
dirigeants que j'ai reçus ont exclu
l'hypothèse d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale
laquelle d'ailleurs n'est à mes yeux pas
justifié à ce jour
beaucoup ont aussi fait part de leur
disponibilité pour avancer sur des
sujets majeurs est urgent pour votre
quotidien le pouvoir d'achat le travail
les moyens d'atteindre le plein emploi
la transition écologique la sécurité je
crois qu'il est donc possible dans le
moment crucial que nous vivons de
trouver une majorité plus large et plus
claire pour agir
vous le savez je suis convaincu de la
nécessité du dépassement politique
depuis le premier jour je les largement
pratiqué et il répond je laissais à
l'aspiration de nombreux d'entre vous de
sortir au fond des querelles et des
postures politiciennes de bâtir par le
dialogue le compromis le travail
collectif
je souhaite donc dans les prochaines
semaines que ce dépassement politiques
se poursuivent avec clarté
responsabilités d'abord la clarté ça
veut dire ne jamais perdre la cohérence
du projet que vous avez choisi en avril
dernier c'est un projet d'indépendance
pour notre pays la france est dans notre
europe que nous devons rendre plus
fortes qui passe par une défense forte
et ambitieuse une recherche d'excellence
une industrie et une agriculture plus
puissante par des investissements
d'avenir un projet de progrès sociaux en
particulier pour notre école et notre
santé qu'il faut refonder sur lesquels
nous devons ré investir un projet de
progrès écologique par une planification
et des investissements assumer un projet
de sécurité et de justice mais aussi un
projet responsable c'est-à-dire crédible
et financé
pour ce faire dès cet été il nous faudra
prendre nous le savons des mesures
d'urgence pour répondre aux besoins du
pays et de votre quotidien une loi pour
le pouvoir d'achat et pour que le
travail paie mieux des premières
décisions pour aller vers le plein
emploi des choix forts sur l'énergie et
le climat des mesures d'urgence pour
notre santé qu'il s'agisse de notre
hôpital ou de l'épidémie tous ces
progrès ne saurait être financé ni par
plus d'impôts ni par plus de dettes
budgétaires et écologique c'est pourquoi
notre pays plus que jamais a besoin de
réformes ambitieuses pour continuer de
créer plus de richesse plus de travail
et innover davantage
ça fait la clarté la responsabilité
ensuite il faudra bâtir comme je
l'expliquais des compromis d
enrichissement des amendements mais le
faire en toute transparence à ciel
ouvert si je puis dire dans une volonté
d'union et d'action pour la nation qui
concerne toutes les forces politiques à
commencer par la majorité présidentielle
mais toutes les autres mais aussi les
forces vives les partenaires sociaux les
élus les associations nous tous pour
cela il faudra clarifier dans les
prochains jours la part de
responsabilité et de coopération que les
différentes formations de l'assemblée
nationale sont prêtes à prendre
entrer dans une coalition de
gouvernement et d'action s'engager à
voter simplement certains textes notre
budget lesquels pour avancer utilement
il revient maintenant aux groupes
politiques de dire en toute transparence
jusqu'où ils sont prêts à aller
demain et vendredi je vous représenterez
au conseil européen nous allons examiner
en particulier la question décisive de
la candidature à l'adhésion de l'ukraine
entre on a notre union européenne et du
contexte géopolitique dès mon retour à
la lumière des premiers choix les
premières expressions des groupes
politiques de notre assemblée nationale
nous commencerons à bâtir cette méthode
est cette configuration nouvelle voilà
mes chers compatriotes ce que ce soir je
voulais vous dire j'ai confiance dans
l'esprit de responsabilité de tous j'ai
surtout confiance en vous en nous vous
avez en avril et en juin fait deux choix
clair et j'en prends acte ma
responsabilité c'est de les faire vivre
et de les faire vivre à votre service
pour que la france soit plus forte et
que les réponses soient plus adaptée
construites différemment mais plus
adaptée aux défis de votre quotidien et
du pays je n'aurais qu'une boussole que
nous avancions au service de l'intérêt
général
et j'ai confiance parce qu'ensemble nous
avons traversé tant de crise tant de
difficultés ces dernières années que je
sais que tous ensemble nous trouveront
le chemin de la réussite collective
je vous remercie vive la république et
vive la france
voilà pour
allocution du président de la république
huit minutes 8 petites minutes c'était
court guillaume roquette premières
impressions ben on a le sentiment que le
président la république a suivi la
feuille de route qu'on imaginait avant
de l'entendre parler c'est à dire dans
une première partie de son intervention
il a expliqué qu'il avait entendu le
message en n'omettant pas et il a eu
raison de dire à quel point le niveau de
l'abstention il ya quasiment un français
sur deux qui ne votent pas ou qui ne
votent plus était important
il a compris qu aucune force politique
ne pouvait plus gouverner seul ne
pouvait plus faire voter les lois seul
est ensuite très vite
emmanuel macron est parti dans une dans
une phase de proposition une phase
constructive en disant eh bien oui il a
refait un petit programme voilà c'est ça
l'a dit nous nous y surtout il a dit
puisque nous ne pouvons plus nous la
majorité faire passer des lois tout seul
et bien nous allons tendre la main aux
différents aux différentes
représentations de l'assemblée nationale
alors il ne cite pas de partir il ne dit
pas je fais des propositions à l air au
parti socialiste au rassemblement
national ou ou à la nuque pourquoi pas
non il dit en gros c'est une sorte
d'appel aux bonnes volontés il attend
que tous les groupes de l'assemblée
nationale 10 un petit peu ce qu'ils sont
prêts à faire jusqu'à quel niveau de
coopération ils sont prêts à aller
très intéressant c'est que il dit il ne
faut pas perdre de vue la cohérence du
projet c'est-à-dire en gros il vous
m'avez quand même élu il ya un mot ni
exactement vous m'avez élu pression de
la république alors ça commence par des
idées il commence par dire ddd des
phrases un peu général du monde est
d'accord le progrès social bah oui ça
forcément le progrès écologique qui
serait content le progrès économique
naturellement ensuite ça devient un
petit peu plus précis parce qu'il dit il
faut il faut distribuer du pouvoir
d'achat il faut prendre des mesures pour
le climat et pour la santé mais sans
augmenter les impôts et sans augmenter
la dette donc ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir trouver de l'argent ailleurs et
évidemment c'est là que ça va devenir
compliqué si on les écoute je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez mais il l'a
presque vous en fait non cette forme de
de
système à l'allemande à l'italienne il a
donné les exemples de ces deux pays
c'est presque mieux moi pourquoi pas
allons-y travaillons comme ça
enthousiaste presque oui parce que
d'abord il faut bien qu'ils fassent
contre maugréer évidemment en plus parce
qu'il sait que c'est une attente des
français il dit d'ailleurs et c'est
assez juste de vous rouler voilà c'est
ça alors il dit vous voulez qu'on
travaille autrement vous voulez plus de
+ 2 vous voulez du compromis vous volez
du dialogue vous voulez du respect c'est
cette forme d'union à laquelle je
faisais allusion tout à l'heure et en
même temps il dit je n'oublie pas que
vous m'avez élu président de la
république et c'est pour ça que la
france ne peut pas fonctionner comme
l'italie ou comme l'allemagne où
effectivement les partis forment
ensemble des coalitions le mas qui sont
libres de le faire en france vous avez
un une autre légitimité qui est celle du
président de la république et c'est
quand même lui qui mène le jeu le ton il
n'est pas abattu le président de la
république presque enthousiasme on avait
l'habitude dans ses allocutions de le
voir le ton grave alors évidemment
pendant la pandémie c'était somme toute
normal mais non je le trouvais
enthousiasmant oui et il a l'air assez
serein peut-être qu'il se dit que ça
peut être une période intéressante parce
que vous savez le le président de la
république c'est c'est un homme très
intelligent thème qui a eu plusieurs
vies notamment celle de banquiers
d'affaires et quand vous êtes banquier
d'affaires vous imaginez des deals vous
vous dit tiens il ya un chemin étroit
pour rapprocher deux entreprises il faut
réussir à faire des propositions qui
peuvent convenir aux deux parties et on
a ce sentiment que oui il a déjà une
forme de 2,2
de satisfaction à imaginer une autre
façon de gouverner maintenant il
n'ignore pas que ça va être très
compliqué où furent surtout qu'ils nous
disent était très fou son discours je me
demande s'il n'a pas pris la parole
juste pour le d'un symbole de dire qu'il
est dans l'action c'est ce qu'on disait
au début il était un peu obligé le
président quand même un oui parce que il
dit
je m'en vais je m'absente pour quelques
jours et en fait il a
il a renvoyé la balle aux partis qui
sont minoritaires à son mais nationale
en disant moi quand je rentrerai je vais
rien quel est le degré de coopération
dont ils font preuve et c'est assez
intelligent c'est tout ce qu'on pouvait
pressentir bâtir en toute transparence à
ciel ouvert sous-entendu les français
vont vous regardez mes chers amis de
l'opposition ne fait pas n'importe quoi
parce que je me priverais pas de vous
montrer du doigt en disant que c'est
vous qui bloquer le pays a exactement et
les français ils veulent ils veulent
qu'on dialogue ils veulent du compromis
ils veulent du respect donc si vous êtes
dans une opposition trouve trop franche
si vous êtes dans une volonté
d'obstruction alors je pourrais
peut-être retourner la situation en sa
faveur en disant moi j'ai tendu la main
et on n'y a pas répondu
de propos autour d'un gouvernement
d'union nationale non d'ailleurs il a
dit que tu es un peu bizarre il a dit on
a parlé d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale mais c'est en gros ce n'est
pas le moment sauf que il n'y a pas de
raison de ne pas croire fabien roussel
quand il dit que c'est précisément ce
que le président lui a proposé mais
alors qu'il avait retiré parce qu'il
l'aurait proposé à fabien roussel qui
lui est sorti en novembre où il m'en a
parlé papa olivier faure alors que bon
pourquoi fabien
paoli vielles force est toujours très
écoutée peu cette vie dans l'intimité de
ces rendez-vous et wii puis vous savez
on dirige une période assez compliquée
donc qu'est ce que fait le président de
la république et est il teste des
scénarios ont fait des propositions qui
soient pas complètement abouti à réagir
et se dit tiens si j'essayais ça peut
être oui excuses et puis si vous êtes
intelligent et tu sais que c'est son cas
vous pouvez laisser entendre à votre
interlocuteur des choses que lui peut
avoir compris ce de façon très
affirmative alors même que vous ne les
avez que suggérez on est là on le voit
bien on entre dans une période de
tâtonnements en gros emmanuel macron dit
ok on veut pas continuer comme avant il
faut qu'on trouve des nouvelles
solutions jeux peuvent plus gouverner
tout seul donc qui m'aime me suive et
qui a
présent à l'esprit l'intérêt des
français me suivra évidemment ça va
devenir compliqué quand on va en arriver
au concret oui on va rentrer dans le dur
rappelez-nous l'aller les prochaines
échéances parce qu'il va falloir d'abord
nommer un président de l'assemblée
nationale et puis après on aura le 5
juillet
pauli le discours de politique générale
absolument alors là là le président de
l'assemblée nationale il va être élu par
les par les députés il ya des postes
importants c'est qu'ils doivent être
pourvus notamment la présidence de la
commission et vous avez que c'est un
poste qui désormais est choix c'est dans
le règlement intérieur de l'assemblée à
un membre de l'opposition mais on ne dit
pas acquis et oui quelle opposition
parce que tout le monde le veut et tout
le monde semble pouvoir la voir vous
presque exactement et puis il va y avoir
effectivement ce moment important qui
sera la déclaration de politique
générale du premier ministre a priori
d'elisabeth banques puisque il ne l'a
pas cité non pas du tout on ça laisse
entendre que qu'elle est toujours dans
le circuit mais vous remarquez quand
même que sous la vème république c'est
le premier ministre qui est le chef de
la majorité or des n'ayant pas cité on
voit qu'il ne lui donne pas un rôle
central donc en gros elle est là à
messier mois que j'entends c'est à dire
que la cité aurait été lui mettre une
forme de pression mais ne pas la citer
ses dires bombay n'est pas si importante
que ça en tout cas il n'a pas dit j'ai
chargé madame la première ministre de de
contacter les différents groupes
parlementaires en vue d' imaginer une
éventuelle coalition et d'ailleurs c'est
lui même et qui reçoivent les
responsables de partis depuis depuis
lundi et et il l'a fait campagne quand
il a reçu christian jacob il l'a fait
seul elisabeth mans n'était pas là c'est
dire
est qu'ils sont dans ce cas là où
qu'elle n'a pas dans le dispositif le
emmanuel macron et vous me connaissez
mieux que moi
il a envie de prendre les choses en main
ça doit presque à stimuler la l'excité
politique monde de pouvoir vivre une
nouvelle page comme ça de sa politique
et tenter autre chose et prendre les
choses en main il n'a pas délégué alors
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
il occupe pleinement depuis le début de
son premier quinquennat le fauteuil du
président de la république c'est vrai
que même s'il n'a jamais dit comme
nicolas sarkozy que le premier ministre
est un collaborateur on va dire qu'ils
n'ont ils n'en pensait pas moins et donc
le paradoxe est que il est peut être le
premier responsable de ce qui se passe
puisque
c'est à lui que les français n'ont pas
voulu donner une majorité claire et
solide celle qu'il appelait de ses voeux
et en même temps effectivement la
solution ne peut venir que de lui parce
que c'est l'interlocuteur des français
dès qu en france il se passe quelque
chose d'important y compris d'un point
de vue institutionnel sévère le chef de
l'état compte tout en est d'ailleurs sur
you tube whip web qui nous dit à quoi
sert bornes on va peut-être se poser la
question à terme les spécialistes de la
communication politique s'en chargeront
mais un mot quand même d'une requête sur
ce cadre là le jardin
le bleu autour est ce que vous y voyez
quelque chose pas forcément on époque le
port de symboles partout écoutez oui
quand vous faites des choix ça a
toujours un sens le pression' république
aurait pu être assis à son bureau
ça aura été plus solennel là il est dans
une dans un cadre presque champêtre
celui du jardin comme si on était dans
un moment important mais qui n'était pas
forcément un moment dramatique de
travail je ne dis pas que ça relativise
la crise que nous traversons
mais on va dire que ce n'est pas le
degré maximum de solennité maintenant qu
attendre d' emmanuel macron là dans les
jours à venir leur nom c'est cette
tournée européenne cette séquence
internationale mais il va devoir
remettre les mains dans le contenu très
vite qu'ils allaient programme comment
il va devoir agir alors il l'a dit un il
a dit je pars pour quelques jours vous
représenter à la fois au niveau européen
puis au sommet de l'otan à madrid et
ensuite quand je rentrerai je ferai le
point pour savoir
ceux ci
les principaux groupes politiques de
l'assemblée nationale ont reçu mon
message s'il si l'acte est de saisir la
main que je leur temps et on peut
imaginer que le discours quand il
rentrera sera déjà un petit peu moins
consensuel qui dira bargach est plus
dans le combat ben c'est pas exclu parce
que là évidemment c'est quand même lui
qui a été un échec donc il peut pas il
peut pas apparaître comme entre
guillemets le l'agresseur mais
son idée c'est que une fois que ce c'est
ce principe de coopération
voire peut-être de coalition or à
infuser dans l'opinion publique s'il ya
un refus des autres partis il pourra le
leur reprocher et prendre les français à
témoin adeline qui me dit sur
lefigaro.fr macron nana plus de
réélection n'a plus de mandat après
celui ci il n'est obligé à rien
finalement est-ce qu'il peut se dire eh
bien je ne respecte rien s'ensuivent oui
mais un peu supérieure mais voyez ce que
je veux dire bon bah je fais ce que je
veux et puis on verra bien et puis
d'après moi le désert et puis j'y vais
quoi alors il pourrait effectivement se
contenter d'être un président qui
inaugure les chrysanthèmes comme sous la
quatrième république d'avoir un simple
rôle à la fois de représentation
institutionnelle et de 2,2 un rôle
international puisque c'est
traditionnellement la mission du chef de
l'état sauf que comme il l'a dit au
début de son intervention
le pouvoir la responsabilité d'une
majorité ça consiste à faire passer des
lois il y a il l'a dit les urgences dans
une vidéo qu'il ne peut pas rester comme
une sorte de sonar d'achat notamment à
dire bon puisque m'avait pas donné de
majorité ben voilà on fait plus rien on
reste comme ça ce serait ce serait
incompréhensible pour les français merci
beaucoup d hommes rejettent je crois
qu'on a on a fait le tour de ce débrief
comme on dit cette allocution courte 1
vous attendiez ce la cour il l'était est
ce qu'il a été assez clair aller tient
le mot de la fin on s'attendait dès fois
on trouve un peu vague un peu long est
ce que là il a été clair précis concis
alors oui je pense qu'il a été assez
clair
je tends la main et j'attends de voir si
on la saisit il me semble que c'est un
message qui a la foi est relativement
concis et qui correspond à l'état
d'esprit des français aujourd'hui je
trouve que politiquement c'est une
séquence qui est plutôt bien joué sans
prendre trop de risques et on attend de
voir merci beaucoup guillaume roquette
évidemment on continue à parler de cette
allocation on en parlera demain on aura
d'autres lives sur figaro live sur et
bien cette allocution sur la politique
sur les jeux politiques et sur les
déplacements des manuels macro
évidemment qui est à bruxelles demain
merci de nous avoir suivis excellente
soirée sur fire like